[Music]
hey lisa what are we going to go do
we're gonna go
go on the vote
[Music]
goes on and on and on the line stretched
outside of the school
millions of people mailing in their
ballots and finding hours
long waits at the polls as far as what's
to come i can only trust god
we are tracking what could be the
largest election turnout in u.s history
i made a plan to vote because i am not
leaving
anything up to chance one of the most
important elections of our lifetimes
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
love it awesome thank you so much
[Music]
it is currently 5 15 a.m i am walking
across campus to meet a few other
students who are also going to be poll
workers
morning doctor thanks for being with us
every place in the country people should
be using mass when they vote we have to
do those things ourselves to change the
course
it's kind of paradoxical that although
the pandemic would make people more
concerned about coming here
but at the same time the government's
reaction to the pandemic
uh all of that instigated more fear that
made people want to come and vote yeah
you know the difference is with
emotionally is the mass
you know and getting used to the mass
and getting used to people being around
you some with man
some without mess the main thing is we
get out and
vote regardless we don't let things stop
us from getting out
yes wear the mask when you go
voting they made sure you had your mask
on it was safe to do so
what motivated you to come out and vote
in this election
uh i was just hoping to make
america great again to keep it that way
early voting started this morning and it
runs through the end of the month
number of voters that are deciding to
vote early record
number of americans taking advantage of
early voting
i just wanted to make sure i did my due
diligence and actually came in
so if i come here i'll stick my ballot
in the box and i'm good to go
the fact that people are waiting so
patiently is a good thing on one hand
but it's
also it's also a reminder that shouldn't
be like this i need you to not only wear
it on your mask
and i don't need you to post it on
facebook that hashtag is doing
absolutely nothing
we gotta vote like history in the making
ladies and gentlemen
some voters waited in line for close to
three hours after
three train rides and a car ride i was
finally able to successfully cast my
ballot
all done not too much social distancing
but everybody had on a mask so
we're all done it's been a hell of a
year for
from the pandemic from everything we
went to i'm a small business owner
so i've really seen a lot of change but
trump will bring it back i'm worried
about
what's going to come after the election
what's going to happen throughout the
day
is there going to be any kind of
violence is there going to be any sort
of initiative
to try to uh disregard their results or
try to put doubt
in the legitimacy of our elections
that's where my concern lies
are mostly focused on male ballots
remaining
this is a tight race and there are any
number of ballots that have not been
counted
because of these delays we were getting
ready
for a big celebration power can't be
taken or asserted
it flows from the people okay so the
relief of voting is that you know your
vote's in there
you you stood for something and that's
what counts that
yes whether your party win or loses
you're standing for what you believe in
you are in the race yes you're in the
race but mostly for humanity
equality and justice that's right
that's right
[Music]